thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an
honorable wild ride with Stevo I'm here
at tight box packing now home of the
Stevo bobble head doll are you kidding
me get out of here get your bobble head
doll at stevo.com with your yeah dude
baseball tees and everything else it's
so exciting and why is this week's
episode so honorable well because
there's a running theme throughout the
episode about being man enough to admit
when you're wrong and you know there's
something that it's pretty rare about
that it's pretty awesome about that and
uh we talk about it in a lot of
different contexts so this one's really
special man I I do
genuinely love it and man Corey Taylor
he let us know that he talked about
stuff that he's never talked about
publicly so get ready for a lot of
special special stuff and let's get into
it
stoked
what
are you promoting uh my my second solo
album's coming out uh September 15th uh
and then we got some uh
tour dates what August 25th to October
7th some [__] like that I don't know
epic okay okay that clock does not do a
good job of the stand [__]
um cmf2
that's right
because I'm super original with names
preceded by cmft
[Music]
all right let me just
odd out there have you been doing press
all morning huh dude I've been doing
press for the last two days man like I
flew in yesterday morning and just hit
the [__] ground hauling ass I did
actually Bert Kreischer said to say hi
all right we did Uh something's burning
it was me and Gavin Rossdale
it was so weird we're sitting there and
he's butchering fish and chips and we're
just like looking at it it was [__]
hilarious dude do you want a water uh no
I'm okay I'm okay right now yeah yeah
let's keep that in and say ladies and
gentlemen Corey Taylor yeah
finally in person man yeah yeah
Super Rad man um so so where to begin
dude like oh Jesus [__] where'd we leave
off I mean yeah you're about to go on
tour it was going to be like a socially
distanced tour last year yeah that's
right man dude we were I think we were
the first ones to go on the road like we
were the kind of the the test subjects
it was like let's see if they'd [__]
Crash and Burn dude and dude we had a
blast man I mean we it was really weird
because it was all those pods you know
like you had they would they would sell
like a group of uh tickets at a table
and then because you couldn't test
people legally you couldn't test people
before they came in but you could do
temperature checks and [__] and they
said as long as you bought like a
certain amount together they could sit
together but then you had to wear a mask
outside of like the circle like dude it
was so weird and yet we were just so
stoked to play for people that we were
like [__] it no it's like playing a lab
why not you know it gives a [__] that's
so funny that you guys were just wearing
masks anyway no this wasn't even slip
knots
like it felt like a jazz club dude it
was weird but so there's just like
little PODS of yeah and how many
different pods in a room it would be
like they would only open up about 25
capacity right so they would and they
would Mark out the pods like around the
tables and [__] and yeah I was it was so
weird but and yet you just loved playing
that we're just like [__] it let's just
get out there and see what happens and
then so the first time we did it it was
great and then the second time we did it
I got coveted literally the last day of
the tour and I was supposed to be flying
into a convention to do an appearance
right so I'm in that I'm in Denver at
the the hotel at the airport and I wake
up and I'm [__] dying I mean I'm like
I'd sweat through the bed it was the
worst I'd ever felt and I was just like
well and I hit up my head of security I
was like you better be bring me a test
because this doesn't feel right sure
enough dude and I spent a week in that
play dude and I at the airport hotel at
the airport hotel in good old Denver
Colorado so I was just like oh for
[__] sake it was brutal dude but I
mean I'm obviously I'm glad I was vaxxed
because it could have been a lot worse
yeah but I mean it only lasted about
three days and then I was good to go
[__] you were in Denver when you got it
flying into the WWE
remember uh I I was in St Louis oh [__]
yeah and then I didn't I would never
have known but like in order to be where
I was at they had to test me right right
I saw the test said I was positive oh I
I would have had no goddamn ideas right
the second time I got it was like that
like I was like I was Abe like
asymptomatic but I was just like oh for
[__] sake man yeah but I and I my uh
my wife's family are older so we're
we're really careful with that [__] you
know so yeah it was like we're not gonna
we we caught it at Christmas so we're
doing like a quarantine Christmas my
wife is up by the door to our bedroom
and we're throwing her gifts it was so
[__] weird I've got that like bungee
cord thing basically yeah it was like it
was hard because I gave her a car that
year and she was like so we had to we
had to follow her out like 10 feet
behind so she could see it and then we
sent her right back you're behind like
SWAT Shields it was weird it's like you
like it yeah you know it's super weird
that's that socially distanced tour yeah
where's your solo band yeah so then by
the time everything opened up that's
when we fired everything back up with
the knot and that was [__] two and a
half years ago I mean I said so and
we've been on the road for two two years
straight like and we were working on the
end so far which is our last album while
we were doing that I was like are we
gonna
take a minute to give people a reason to
come back and nope [__] we just charged
right through so it was it was crazy so
you've been going straight through I've
been working non-stop yeah dude I've
just been hauling ass and you were
touring for a cmft we we stopped on cmft
and then started doing because I did
some pickup stuff here and there yeah
with with my solo stuff
um for the most part it's been hardcore
like uh Slipknot stuff so
um this tour coming up that I'm doing uh
August 25th that's all all solo stuff
with one Slipknot show right in the
middle to kind of [__] things up yeah
where's the Slipknot show at Blue Ridge
and then how far away is it from here we
were at Blue Ridge yeah I'm actually
doing Blue Ridge two days later with my
solo thing so I'm in four days I'm doing
solo slip knot Solo solo day off I'm
like I'm an idiot okay it was like right
in the middle of covid I was crowd
surfing
at the music the Blue Ridge Music
Festival right right yeah man that was
it that was a Cool vibe dude that whole
place those people we played it last
year and we were we weren't sure how it
was going to go because it was dumping
rain and we get we hit the stage dude
and this Roar came up and we were like
okay we're gonna be all right this is
[__] awesome great people man it was
really cool and Scott's like been the
most uptight about covid right and like
we're traveling there together we're
like in a rental car together and he's
like dude well because he has the idea
that he wants a crowd serve so he called
Dr Drew oh and he's like hey what are
the chances and he's like well I
wouldn't advise you do that right but we
have it on camera too and like he how
many times did you crowd serve you went
up and back a couple different times
yeah there's raps I didn't get it this
time I'm about to [__] get these next
six times right yeah yeah wow how do you
keep track of like remembering all those
songs with like is it hard when you have
all your albums that you're touring for
then you switch to a slip knot like is
there do you have to sit in the hotel
and like read what you say man you ask a
good question I luckily have not gone
into like a different band song during
another's band set yeah yeah I haven't
gone completely [__] bad [__] but
um I don't know ma'am I I
compartmentalize pretty pretty well and
when you're in the mask
and that keeps you kind of in that
moment you know like definitely have the
mask on just keeps me in that head space
so I mean if I ever go into a different
song when I'm wearing the mask do you
know where to check me in at that point
it's like yeah we gotta send him yeah
he's starting to [__] lose it yeah
you ever been to a Grateful Dead show
and Jerry [__] up the lyrics and
everybody just cheers
I don't remember that yeah there's
there's like YouTube videos of him like
I'm sure well dude I've I've had songs
where like I'll start a song and then
I'll just blank yeah like I'm just like
what do you what do you do how do you
play it I'll laugh and I restart the
song I'm like [__] at that point that's
all you can do sometimes that is the
biggest cheer of the show and it lets
people know that they're in a moment man
right so many [__] people either play
at a track or they're not playing at all
and it's just like it's just a [__]
mechanical motion for them and there's
no vibe there's no heart to it are you
saying that there's people still doing
Millie Vanilli types yes I am now the
the hip-hop Community gets a pass
because largely what they'll do is
they'll throw the track on and then they
rhyme over the top of it but you can
hear the double track on that so you
know they're doing it but they're
actually singing it live singing along
to themselves however there are people
in my genre who sing not only have tons
of Pro Tools going on but they're not
physically singing as well they're just
yeah wow yeah I remember I did Warp Tour
years ago and there were bands like that
and there was one band like sound
checking they were like [__] we lost our
laptop charger like we don't know what
to do and then like a like legit punk
band was like are you [__] kidding me
like and they're asking like do you want
to have like a cord for uh and they're
like I have a guitar chord I have a bass
chord I don't have a computer cord for
you like I also have this ball sack
because I do it myself yeah exactly
I'm a [__] [__] though like I and
I should I shouldn't do that because
some friends I have use those and they
use them for a reason that that's their
piece that's their truth but I just
there's no way dude like I couldn't do
it of course when I was we were doing
Stone Sour and we put out the two uh the
two concept albums House of Gold and
Bones albums we used track as uh filler
for some of the tunes that we played
obviously all the guitars were real the
drums were real vocals were real bass
was real but we used track for some of
the uh like orchestral stuff right and
like some of like the the connector
pieces because we were playing some of
the stuff that would connect
and being a slave to that felt so
stifling that I was like losing my I was
like we're gonna get off this [__]
[__] I hate being chained to a click I
hate being chained to something where I
can't because the part of the
fun of live is the push and pull man
like you can tell when somebody's
feeling it because the song is way
[__] faster than the original you
know like they're just in it or it's
heavier or they slow it way down
that to me is the epitome of live man
because you're feeling it like they're
in that [__] moment and there's no
denying that it's them playing it and
that to me that's the beauty of playing
live who do you think's the best band
Live let me tell you something a good
rock band is just like a good razor high
quality killer performance and no
gimmicks that just drive up the price
for no reason man and that's why Harry's
is the rock star of all shaving products
man you got the five blade razor that is
as good a quality as any razor in the
world no gimmicks this is the only thing
I shave my face with is my Harry's
razors and now get ready for an exciting
offer from Harry's only for the
listeners of the Wild Ride podcast you
got the craft handle Starter Set this is
a weighted ergonomic handle with these
cool grips on it and I'm telling you it
just feels good gotta have that the five
blade razor the travel cover to protect
the razor the foaming shave gel this
whole starter kit is valued at 17 but
the listeners with the Wild Ride podcast
get it for only ten dollars so to snag
this deal go to
harrys.com
Stevo one more time
harry's.com slash Devo for the craft
handle starter kit and you gotta jump on
it now now let's get back to it
oh dude first one that comes to mind
Allison James Alice they're so [__] I
mean Jerry
I mean the whole band is amazing and the
way that Sean Kenny the drummer swings
as he plays because everything for them
is naturally slower
um and the things that they do to
manipulate the Rifts because they're so
sludgy anyway but the the way they lock
in together is [__] unreal like
they're so good that it's criminal to
this day they're that good everybody's
with their manager uh Chuck oh yeah
truck truck Randall yeah man great dude
love that dude yeah yeah he's uh he's a
little bit of a mentor to me oh nice
yeah next time you talk to him tell him
I said hey okay I haven't seen him in a
minute he's a great dude yeah and I
remember Chuck inviting me to some big
Festival Alice in Chains is playing as
well as tool and oh [__] yeah I'm saying
tool is the best live tool I tell you
what
tool to me is an acquired taste because
they're so
they're so dialed that it's almost like
listening to the album and that to me as
a punk kid growing up that that's not
necessarily where I'm at they're amazing
at what they do
but when I go to a show I want to see
something as well right and because
they're not they're not as demonstrably
adaptive I I get bored and I hate to say
that that's that's not because they're
boring it's because I'm myself bored
because I'm so used to [__] like Napalm
death you know where Barney's walking up
walls and jumping on people's heads you
know but they what they do dude is so I
mean Danny Kerry is one of the greatest
[__] drummers of all time dude you
know and the way they mesh together as a
band is so
effortless and just I mean they take you
there I mean and they'll they'll
extrapolate stuff for minutes upon
minutes to getting you there and it's
longer than the album and you're just
like they're just pulling you in and
you're like
you know it's crazy but to me
maybe I should go and sleep now prob as
older I would probably appreciate it
more than I did when I was younger you
know yeah how about this uh Power Trip
Festival
October like Jesus
so basically
every big band on the planet so it's
Metallica
roses AC DC and there's one more tool
tool yeah whoa and they had Aussie but
Ozzy it backed out he had to drop out we
know who's replacing Ozzy I don't know
if they are I don't think it's I think
they flicked it so it's all like one
weekend yeah it's like four days of just
Stadium [__] it's wow I think it's the
same place where they do uh um India
California yeah Coachella Coachella
right where Coachella is done so it's
like so they're just like okay [__] your
hippie [__] here's this you know and I'm
like who else could you get this is
Metallica playing it yeah yeah I was
just talking to Lars about it
um he was just like yeah we're doing
this Power Trip thing man and I'm like I
don't know what to do I'm like you guys
are going out this is gonna be [__]
nuts dude there's not gonna be any metal
heads left on the planet they're all
gonna be in the desert yeah yeah that's
[__] crazy it's crazy I was just
watching a YouTube clip on Metallica
when they played to like 1.5 million
people Russia right yeah I mean it's is
that accurate 1.5 million people have
you seen that video I saw uh I saw
something on social media where it was
like this is what 1.5 million people
looks like and then swipe and then this
is what 100 000 looks like and then
swipe and this is like what 1000 looks
like right and and I swiped all the way
through it but then I went back to the
1.5 million people and it didn't look
any different than the 100
000 I I kind of didn't because you
couldn't all those people into frame
it's pretty crazy how are they how they
just ticket sales it was the first
really big heavy band that had ever
played Russia there's 91 91 91 because
it was right after the Black Album came
out Metallica by that time is arguably
the biggest band on the planet because
remember guns was out at that time and
they were doing usual illusion
so metallic and this before the guns and
Metallica Tour that they did
they got they're out there as before
James got lit up is before the explosion
hit him oh [__] yeah so it was right in
that time frame
they're the biggest band in the world in
the universe at that point every at up
to that point that I get I'd say the
most modern show that had ever been
played in Moscow was the Peace festival
that happened in 89 which was Motley Bon
Jovi uh Cinderella
um I mean it was like [__] Skid Row
was there uh scorpions and they were
doing the the
uh Motley was claiming they were sober
yeah yeah it was well and that was one
of the reasons why they were doing it
was to to promote that and yet then Ozzy
was on it you know and so and Zach tells
all these horror stories about the plane
ride over where everybody was [__]
just
[__] face dude and you're just like oh
my God but I think that was the most
modern show that had been because
remember the curtain was kind of still
on and off at that point yeah 87 yeah so
80 89 the Wall came down yeah yeah
um
so a 91 Metallica hits the biggest band
in the [__] world everybody and their
mom is going to that show you know what
I'm saying because it wasn't like it
wasn't like even 10 years ago where
Russia was kind of a spot on your tour
like you did rush I've played mosque
I've Moscow many times you know not
anymore but at the time nobody did it so
word got out and you think about how big
Russia is you're gonna [__] make your
way to that show you're going to get to
that show so 1.5 honestly in my opinion
maybe a small number because there I
mean there could have been [__] it
could have been like the original
Woodstock where they just stopped taking
tickets and it was just everybody in
their [__] mom coming over you know
the you know Juniors Farm they're just
like we're going to [__] see this
[__] yeah so good man yeah did I see
something in the news recently some like
about um just some
love for Jason newstead like everything
like they think so yeah they've really I
think it's one of the things they've
been opening up about because in
retrospect and maybe it's because they
started to talk about it now it's like
the way that how they handled it yeah
and the more they're like really
exploring how they handle him they
really [__] they hurt him man I mean
yeah for people who don't know Jason is
dead was okay he's the one who replaced
cliffberg in Metallica after Cliff died
I see Cliff died in 1986. yeah on tour
with Ozzy yeah they were they were on a
bus the bus had a slippery Road in
Scandinavia and it flipped over oh he's
the only one that died the only one that
died and they had they had drawn straws
to about like which bunk they were gonna
sleep in and I forget if uh Cliff got
the longest star he he Cho he got first
choice and according to the story
he wanted Kirk's bunk so he switched
bunks with Kirk so at when the when the
bus accident happened he was in that
bunk when it could have been Kirk who
who died so it's like it's a I mean the
the myth the Mythos over surrounding
that accident is so huge you can
actually drive to that spot and there's
a memorial where where Cliff died like
it's that it's that powerful
um and it's three hours out of the way
it's crazy man I mean it's one of those
drives where today a band at that level
would probably fly because of the the
terrain and how crazy it gets up there
um so they replaced the replacement
Jason who was the bass player for a band
called
and he's a massive Metallica fan
um they had a lot of people actually try
out for the spot and then including
um
a guy from Primus let's play pool
actually try it out and they were like
this is interesting but this isn't us
yeah it's crazy right right
um could you imagine Les Claypool with
Metallica like put the [__] [__]
you're just like I think that that it
just uh from a type A personality type
thing that that wouldn't have worked it
would have been a totally different band
too many chiefs exactly
um so that's when they people say like
Metallica turned down less Claypool
that's the reason why because I've
always heard that I'm like why would
they turn it down well they turned him
down because honestly at the time it
didn't make sense you know and honestly
this was before Primus was even a
household name you know everybody people
need to remember the first album that
Jason did was actually the garage Days
album which was the cover album garage
days
re-revisited I still up until a couple
years ago had my original copy I had the
598 ep the cassette because they had the
590 ADP and then they had the uh the 798
vinyl because every it was always
affordable but it was always a different
price for the different format and
whatnot how many tracks can you remember
from Garage Days re-revisited green hell
last correct oh yeah uh Green Hill
Alaska rest there was a the weight yeah
uh there was helpless yeah
um crash course from brain surgery yeah
and there was uh the small hours that's
the whole out and then with uh [__]
oh dude that's one of my favorite albums
of all time it's epic and they built
they recorded it in this garage that
they that they built basically to kind
of do just let's just do something and
Vibe and see what happens so this was
before and justice for all so they
record that they go in it's super
[__] punk rock it's super like yeah
it's dirty and it's a great [__]
album man and that led to going into
doing Injustice for all which a lot of
people think was a reaction to
the fact that they were subliminally
dealing with the death because there's
no base on that album at all really yeah
they're they're you can go on YouTube
and find versions where people have
added bass and they call it and justice
for Jason because they buried him in the
mix I mean it's such a two two-track mix
that you're listening to it going am I
meant what the [__] going on here
because I remember I stood in line
waiting for that album to come out and I
bought it and I listened to it and the
first time I listened to it I was like
this is [__] crushes it's killer and
then I started going well it doesn't
sound as thick as their other stuff you
know but you didn't mind because it was
riffy as [__] you know thick is the base
exactly and they think people talk about
whether or not that was them
subliminally reacting to the fact that
Cliff was dead and purportedly the way
they've they treated Jason over the
years was really really bad and even
James has admitted yeah because I mean
it's it's tough you know I mean you just
lost somebody you were in the trenches
with they were all young they didn't
know how to process grief nobody helped
them process it so what they did was
they took it out on the new guy or got
really [__] up yeah yeah yeah
I mean it was crazy what if it's really
just something special when
people step up and acknowledge
that's right when a man admits that he's
wrong he's done something right and
that's a good thing so we should all
admit that what we're doing to the
environment to Mother Earth with plastic
is wrong and that's why I support liquid
death I support liquid death Big Time
Around Here down at tight box packing we
pound them out of this machine all day
long yeah because we love liquid death
and why is it called liquid death well
not only are they bringing death to
plastic which is destroying the world
with their infinitely recyclable tall
boy cans that are designed to look like
beers but don't be scared it's just
water baby and they don't only do water
now they've got flavored sparkling water
they've got all these killer teas with
funny name flavors like armless Palmer
dude they just don't ever stop and wait
until you see the killer liquid death
campaign that we've got coming out in
the next couple weeks or so
it's scary it's so rad and scary how
they murder your thirst dude liquid
death this is the way to go and for the
listeners of the Wild Ride podcast you
can get 20 off your first apparel
purchase at liquiddeath.com if you add
that slash steamo it's liquiddeath.com
Stevo everything about this company
rules their their merch is epic so grab
that deal for 20 off merge find their
products all over it retailers on Amazon
the rest of it support liquid death
because I love them now let's get back
to it
that's really big and it's it's
something that and this is how sad it is
when it happens it it catches You by
surprise because not a lot of people do
it right which you wish it was the
opposite you know it's like you wish
that it would just be something that you
just take for granted it's like of
course oh [__] of course man my bad I I
was totally in the wrong if more people
right would own everything they do not
just the good [__] the bad man you would
just I think there would be more of an
embracing of humanity as a whole big
time yeah an example of that which I I
think is just so epic
Bill Clinton after his presidency right
stepped up to acknowledge his failure to
intervene on what happened in Rwanda
right right and that was really and he's
100 correct to be you know like he
really it was in his hand right and he
you know cause genocide he was totally a
genocide right oh 100 yeah yeah why
should on him just because he's a bass
player I mean you wouldn't do that if
you brought on a new singer well it's
largely because they didn't like I said
they didn't know how to deal with grief
and even though J and I think one of the
things is because Jason was such a nice
guy
it was a little bit like karabi coming
into the crew where he was like dude I
can't believe I'm in Metallica and
they're like buddy we're not looking for
a fan right we're looking for a basis
we're looking for somebody who's gonna
you know help us take it because one of
the reasons why Robert works is because
Robert was Robert for years you know
he's a fan but he also knows how to hold
his own whereas Jason came in and was
just you know like you know you [__]
grew up listening to Metallica yeah like
they had done shows together on
festivals and whatnot he was a [__]
fan
so when you're already dealing with the
negativity of grief
and you also compound it with alcohol
your your perspective on some [__] like
that can be skewed and a harsh
how do I say this nicely a harsh
personality will dissect that and then
destroy you for it
someone that positive and that stoked
about life yeah coming into that
situation with three people who are
really [__] hurting
you add alcohol and
you know repression
and they're going to they're going to go
you know what you're done I'm going to
shred you I'm going to [__] and that's
that's sad it's human nature though I
think there's another level too of just
um like the the type A like the the
rights the Chiefs thing right just
there's a level of conditioning of it
yeah yeah and and Lars and James are
kind of notorious for that oh what album
was it for uh what a fun Deep dive into
Metallica right yeah but to go even
further what album uh was it for the
West Memphis Three oh well I mean they
were using the soundtrack of Master of
Puppets right yeah it was uh uh Joe
Berlinger the director I believe was the
director for some kind of um
yeah so he's he's been friends with them
for years and he used that he used their
music to kind of help convey that story
yeah I mean it was powerful it's very
powerful man like especially knowing the
background on this I know a lot about
that because I was a part of the the
Black Flag tribute album that Henry put
out to raise money for their legal
defense and whatnot I tried to help kind
of spread as much wow yeah it was crazy
man when did Henry do that this was 2002
no this was years ago and he actually
used Mother Superior he used his Henry
Rollins band at the time which was uh
Jim Wilson and Mother Superior to
recreate all of those Black Flag albums
so he had guest people come in and sing
everything so I did uh oh [__] I did uh
uh room 13.
um did Ian Makai get on that no I don't
think so
um but he did have Keith Morris was on
it
um Keith came into saying something uh
Dean ween did [__] gimme gimme gimme
and it shredded I mean dude I was like
what the [__] I mean it was so good dude
it's probably one of my favorite
versions of that song man it's really
good iced tea did um police story
um like it's it's hard to find now but
it's called called
um oh God damn it what's it called
it's called I can't remember what the uh
look it up yeah it's the uh rise above
it's called it's called rise above and
it's the the the album to raise money
for the West Memphis Three and it's
crazy cool it's crazy a black flag
between Rollins and Greg gin like it's
two totally different bands right you
know it's kind of like Van Halen like
just two totally different bands and and
I just can't imagine what rolling
Rollins would never have sung gimme
gimme gimme right or no but at the same
time he did he re-sang a lot of stuff on
that album with that band so he was able
to recreate it like they did they did
slip it in
um
I think they redid my War like there's a
lot [__] rat which damn that song
you're just like unless you wrote that
song There's no way to really recreate
it you're just like it's [__] great
it's one of the craziest piece of music
I've ever [__] heard yeah my War yeah
and that the whole in my head album oh
so good
that's I mean that's one of that's one
of the bands that helped form my
approach to Heavy Music was just the
ferocity and the the the music itself
just how frenetic Greg gin's [__]
playing is and then the way Henry sang
was so intense like atonal but so
intense like you can hear the blood in
his throat dude like you're just like oh
[__] and it just it's like you feel like
you're being hit and you feel like
you're going through what he went
through that inspired everything that he
[__] wrote about yeah yeah isn't it
weird that like all these bands are
getting together to raise money for the
legal defense but can't the legal
defense just give them a 50 discount or
like I mean
they're lawyers well yeah I know that's
the problem with lawyers is exactly you
[__] call them they probably charge
them to take the phone call to let them
know that they're raising the money for
the fund the one if there's one thing
I've learned about lawyers is the only
time they'll [__] be on time to hit
you up about anything is if they haven't
been paid yet when you need something
yeah yeah we'll get to it yeah of course
it's anything billable oh they're coming
for you right man we've moved on such a
deep dive into all this great and stuff
and um
dude I've just been really enjoying that
oh it's okay all right I want to say
that uh that you look [__] fantastic
thanks man thank you I heard somebody
accuse you of being in your 50s I'm
about I turned 50 this year okay me too
next year I'm so I just turned 49. okay
yeah so I'll be 50 in December okay so
yeah yeah how do you feel about it
it's interesting I'm still trying to
kind of piece it together because
physically I feel no different than I
did you know
um I'm a little I mean obviously I got
Slipknot miles on me and [__] you know
but
for the most part I'm I'm okay you know
like I've learned early on that I would
have to physically kind of try to slide
through some of the the [__] that I
never I never had to worry about when I
was younger obviously you know my
recovery a lot longer I'm sober
um I uh how long even sober 13 years now
yeah man um I quit smoking eight years
ago
um I
you know I I try to stay as healthy as I
can obviously
um but I still love shitty food so it's
it's a constant battle especially when
you you have to kind of look good to try
and sell your [__] I get up on stage I'm
like hey ladies
uh yeah that's water weight you know
it's you gotta you kind of have to you
have to do what you have to do to to be
in this business right yeah so I try to
stay as healthy as I can not only look
good but also to be able to perform at
that level
and as I get closer to 50 it's this
weird dichotomy because I don't
necessarily look 50. but there are
definitely mornings when I feel 67.
let's put it out like getting up is an
arduous process do you stretch I try to
man I'm not very sure my wife is way
better at the maintenance stuff because
she's been athletic her whole [__]
life man so she's like on me she's like
you know she's trying to keep me alive
because she likes me I don't know what
the [__] her problem is but um how long
you've been married uh six years well
we've been together for six years we've
been married for four and
um I'm mad at myself for not meeting her
when I was younger let's put it that way
she's that amazing you know wow and uh
she's my best friend man I mean in fact
it's like as soon as I'm done here I run
right to the airport to fly home just so
I can hang out with her you know where
are you flying home to to Vegas yeah I
mean where we were when I did the the
podcast last time yeah yeah so
um do you go to the fights ever in Vegas
no man I I try to stay away from the
strip unless I'm working because it's
just messy you know like every trailer
park in the world is empty and they're
all at the strip and I'm just like oh
for [__] sake I can't I just can't do
and listen I'm not [__] on anybody
live your life do whatever but you have
to understand how messy you are in my
city it's hard for me to get around when
everybody's walking around in neon
thongs and gigantic [__] yeah you
know okay drinks
how long have you lived in Vegas uh 15
years now 14 years wow coming there soon
I know it's it's insane you know what's
really insane is how much money there is
to be made if you can build an audience
online I know some of you have an
audience and maybe you're not monetizing
that Audience by offering cool stuff
that people want and getting it to them
efficiently and affordably and that's
where ship station comes in how do you
think I get all the orders out of tight
box packing like my big old speakers my
new bobble head over here I'm telling
you dude I do it with ship station every
time an order comes in
the label prints out we put the merch in
the Box we slap on the label and we send
it on out we got FedEx coming to the
warehouse to pick up we got UPS we got
United States Postal Service we got them
all and through ship station we get the
best deals that there are to get deals
that are normally reserved for Fortune
500 companies and you know what you can
try this all out yourself very easily
very quickly if you go to
shipstation.com use the promo code Stevo
for your free 60-day trial period I'm
telling you it's that easy it doesn't
matter how you're selling your stuff if
it's on Etsy Amazon eBay your own
website doesn't matter it's one easy
interface and it brings together
everything right on one site and you can
try it for 60 days no risk free trial
I'm telling you guys it's time to make
ship happen so go to shipstation.com and
use the promo code Stevo to start your
risk free trial now let's get back to it
I tell you what
more people have it's the the city has
changed a lot since a lot of the sports
teams have come in and I'm not it's not
a bad thing I love it you know
um I love the fact that the Raiders are
there I love the fact that uh the A's
might be coming there somebody mentioned
the fact that the Kings might be coming
like I mean we're still we went from
having no teams right to then
the knights really was the thing that
set the frenzy off because they weren't
going to bring in any sports teams and
then they were like okay we'll try it
with a hockey team you know money and
I'm telling you dude
and I have a buddy who works with the
knights and he let me know this he's
like we put on the first year that the
knights were there they put out 23
000 season tickets and they sold out
within 15 minutes wow that quick because
that's how that's how much locals wanted
something but hockey yeah they're
[__] great dude they just won the cup
yeah they won the Cup this year they are
the Stanley Cup because Vegas has the
money to get the best team it's because
they took the time and they hand-picked
especially the first year because the
first because they've been they've been
perennially really good they took cast
offs from other teams who were good but
could never get through because the
stars were out shining everybody and
they constructed a [__] clutch team
and I mean of like crazy [__] and
they just started to bear it's it's
crazy that they haven't won more Cups
than they have because they're that good
all right 23 000 season tickets like how
big is this that's maxed that's Max yeah
that's right Arena yeah for us for a
hockey Stadium that's pretty big and
they did it huge they did it immediately
yeah I mean Arena's like 15 000 right
like no it could be 15 to 25 yeah
um some of the because once you get up
into like 40 or 50 that's like Stadium
size yeah and after that it gets up into
the 80s and the hundreds and that's
where it's crazy I saw a headline that
said that um you know now at the
interest rates up the one in four home
buyers is
finding a new state to live in yeah and
the number one city that people are
moving to is Las Vegas yeah oh trust me
I've seen the traffic and I see all the
different [__] license plates and
[__] and I was like you and they all
clog it up but that's fine you know what
about like the Water Crisis like isn't
there like I mean because well well
here's the thing after that whole thing
happened we had about of extreme
rainfall come in so the fact to the
point where our reservoirs have topped
up now which is crazy we had more
rainfall last year than we had the the
five years prior to that okay yeah the
Hoover Dam is like full it was crazy
dude I mean it was I mean living there
having to deal with people who don't
normally have to drive in the rain and
I'm from Iowa so I've driven [__]
every everything you know watching these
asshats freak out because it's damp I
was just like just pull your purse down
go you're not gonna [__] slip and
fall in a Gulch just dry I can see you
doing that in the car too I'm that guy
I'm an [__] that's that's where my my
buddies keep trying to get me to get uh
the Mr Wheeler tattoo you know the the
old Disney cartoon where Goofy's like
the crazy driver that they that's me I'm
that guy so as soon as I get behind the
wheel of car I go from zero to [__]
very quickly it's it's not great but it
can be very funny my wife is just like
oh here he goes it's bad yeah dead love
the way you describe your relationship
with your wife man yeah I've got uh a
fiance I'm similarly in love with nice
nice it's rare dude it's such a rare
Vibe when you meet someone that not only
do you're like you really love and
you're really passionate about but
someone you really [__] like and
that's I mean I'd never I've been
married twice before you know and
first time we were young the second time
was a horrible mistake but and I I
honestly after that divorce I basically
was like that's it I'm never never even
[__] considering this [__] and then I
met the love of my life but it was CR
and it come out of nowhere so yeah
that's special that's one of the
questions I wanted to ask you when I was
driving here is like how important is it
to find that special someone because
probably in your 20s or 30s it's like
you you or you have a band member that's
like in a toxic relationship and they're
outside the studio arguing with them and
they come in and it's like they're not
their head's not into it like it's
really important to have somebody like
that in your life I mean yeah not only
that but somebody that you can feel
supportive of as well man you know what
I'm saying because you want to support
them especially when they're supporting
you as much as possible like you want
that yin and yang and it's I don't know
what the [__] it is but it's very rare
man and when you find somebody like that
you need to hold on to them it's how did
you know she was the one I knew when the
first time she told me exactly what she
[__] felt and she wasn't
she wasn't being mean let's put it that
way my wife
is one of the smartest people I know and
she's also very forthright and she's
never going to scream at you about
anything my wife's never screamed at me
she's but she's gonna let me know her
opinion
and nine times out of ten her Common
Sense defeats my male mammalian ego
lizard [__] and I have to sit back and
go
yeah Foxy's right and she's always nice
about it and that's what kills me it's
like could you just be a dick for a
second just give me that and she's like
no no we're just gonna have this
conversation and I'm gonna leave it with
you
and then you let me know how what you
think and I just kind of and I sit and I
give it about 10 minutes I go
[__] you're right as a man that's hard
sure but once you realize that it's not
an offense
to you as a person
there she's just trying to show you
where you may be mistaken and a better
way to do it it's like it's not
necessarily that she wants you to be
wrong she just wants you to both do
what's correct not even right man you
know so there have definitely been times
where
I haven't talked to her about certain
[__] and I've just made decisions
because I'm a man and sometimes I am
rash you know and she goes you need to
[__] talk to me about some some of
this [__] because some of it's blown
back on me quite badly and I'm just like
oh [__] oh Steve you could talk about
that I can I can relate to all of it
yeah yeah I mean what's been the
difference in your Luck's relationship
because you guys have always had an
upper trajectory but I feel like in the
last year and a half year it's kind of
gone upward even more so what's changed
I think that the the the the first
important piece is that for me it wasn't
about finding the right person nearly as
much as it was about becoming the right
person right and that that's a big part
of it right I would have been absolutely
useless to Lux if I hadn't put in the
work right preemptively to learn how to
be in a healthy relationship right and
uh that took a lot of work I I had a lot
of uh you know I'll have to clean up a
lot of stuff to clean up so you kind of
got to be ready to meet the right person
yeah for sure I mean and it's always
when you least expect it too man you
know like when I was you know before my
wife and I actually even got together we
had met and there was definitely
something there and I told her I was
like I'm not in a spot to be in a
relationship at all how come because I
had a lot of damage yeah oh dude it was
holding me together that's all I had man
like I was I was psychologically
emotionally physically physically [__]
up about it like I had I was a physical
manifestation of all the stress and
toxicity that I dealt with like
childhood trauma or past relationships
past relationship that relationship my
the the my previous second marriage and
did the second marriage ending coincide
with sobriety no I was sober through the
whole thing which is which which meant I
I lived it hard felt everything and I
dude it was in my skin it was in my life
like and I had a lot of [__] happen to
me kind of all at once I had my spinal
injury happen where I had to have spinal
surgery so I couldn't work out so I
couldn't be physical I was still
imbibing a [__] ton of calories but I
wasn't able to burn it and work it
her and I's relationship was at an
all-time low
we were working tirelessly
um I'm not the I can I'm definitely not
the easiest person to live with neither
is she I'm not you know it's it takes
two you know what I mean so I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lay everything at
somebody's feet but there was definitely
the the pure hardest truth is we weren't
meant to be together and it was kind of
like that from the beginning but in the
beginning you don't really pay attention
to anything you don't listen to the
signs
and things just progress by that time
you're married by that time you're like
that there's that thing in you from Iowa
that's like okay just
maybe this is just how it is you know
let's just make it work stoicism you
know all that [__] you know instead of
listening really listening
so by the time I got out of that
relationship I was I didn't even look
like myself if I showed you pictures
you'd be like oh my God it's tough red
hair and all that no I'm long shitty
hair
um then you looked 50. I well I looked
like I was pushing 60 man yeah it was
bad I was overweight
um I you could see it like in my skin
dude I just looked [__] up and I
wasn't I wasn't I wasn't drinking I
wasn't doing drugs I wasn't doing
anything man I just but I looked like it
which was crazy
and
that's when her and I started talking
because I hit her up about opening a
stone sour tour like putting it because
I was putting a tour together and I
wanted I wanted to do something
different her group the cherry bombs are
amazing like there's like this Cirque
type dance troupe that does fire to with
heavy metal music they do aerial they do
it all it's [__] rad and she's a
superhero man and we really hit it off
and I had to be brutally honest with her
I was like I'm not even close to having
processed this and now because I was
always I was I mean I was just honest
crazy Wormhole of like it's kind of
self-discus trying to figure out what
even made me happy man you know
and it wasn't until I kind of pulled my
head back up
I took a breath and it was just like man
I'm still miserable so something's not
right you know and I started working on
myself
luckily by that time we were on tour
together
and she and I you know she was still
hurting from the fact that I had said no
but we had she was still one of the few
people that I really wanted to talk to
because I respect her so much you know
so one thing led to another we started
talking again
and she laid it out for me she's like
you
the the choices that you're making in
your life are gonna bite you in the ass
you need to figure out why you're
miserable and you need to figure out how
to make yourself [__] happy again you
know you need to get back to that point
and she's always been the person to put
it in perspective for me you know and
without any thought of herself to be
honest like she's just like listen
forget it's me
just tell me what is what you're feeling
and tell me what's up so you can start
to kind of figure out how to get back to
a place where you feel good again man
and then one thing led to another and I
just realized I was like I
I don't want to live the rest of my life
I don't want to live one more [__]
day without her and as soon as the we
waited until the tour was done
and we've been together ever since
and that was 2017. and now you take your
anger out on the people in traffic I do
that's a good that's a good outlet for
you do you create better music when
you're depressed or when you're happy I
don't I think that's a cop-out to be
honest because there are a lot I know a
lot of musicians who think that they
write better music when they're [__]
up and I've never been able to at all
man I think music is whatever mood
you're in in that moment you know what I
mean I definitely write
really good
when I'm
feeling something intensely whether it's
anger or
really bereft of uh happiness like
there's a there's a bottom that I can
hit where some really poignant [__]
comes out of me but
some of my favorite music I wrote when I
was really happy you know what I mean
like so so I I don't look for moments to
where to kind of descend on it I I
honestly if I'm feeling it I try to
write it down as quickly as possible
because I know I it comes in waves for
me I'll definitely have moments where
I'm not feeling anything inspiring so
I'm like I'm not going to try to write
anything because I'm not going to try
and force it because it's going to sound
forced you know right but no matter what
whether I'm I'm up or down and I
definitely have moments where I'm super
down
I know that I'm going to be able to
write something that I can then go back
and still relate to later you know so
and I think I'm maybe I'm lucky in that
respect I'm definitely thankful for it
but I've never I've never had to wait
until I was and depressed to write
something I've always had something to
say and it's always felt important for
some reason yeah I always feel like
sometimes people subconsciously
self-sabot like writers subconsciously
self-sabotage themselves so their life
shitty yeah it's always shitty so they
can because I'm a writer yeah you know
exactly and that's is that how they came
up with the genre of the Blues because
it's you're feeling bluesy is that well
no I think that had more to do with the
fact that it was a marriage of gospel
and country that the ant and but it's
always depressing music right but it but
it also came from from the Black Culture
I mean that they started singing it as a
celebration because of the work that
they were doing in the fields uh because
of the the brutality that they were
dealing with in their lives they took
the gospel music the country music that
they were hearing and a lot of the
the music they had brought over from
from Africa and kind of married it
together to create this wholly different
vibe the the the roots of the Blues I
believe are are from that kind of
country western
uh accent but
it's a really good question because I'm
not sure because I mean there's there
are whole documentaries that you can go
and look up and so many people have so
many different answers to it but to me
the spirit of the Blues is really about
singing it away you know what I'm saying
that makes sense for me the best thing
you can do is write something down
because once you write it down it's
physical and you can get a handle on it
if you just let it sit in your head it's
just air man and you can't [__] you
can't get a grip on it and you can't
you can't figure out a way to kind of
shape it to to do something for you you
know yeah I feel like some of the like
Led Zeppelin's best music has to do
around heartache oh it's beautiful man
like and and some of the stuff that
Robert wrote is to this day so ethereal
and I mean you look at the I was just
listening to [__] Stairway to Heaven
last night and I know it's crazy that
somebody just sat down and listened to
to Stairway to Heaven yeah like 21. you
know it's it's I've always forget how
powerful that song is yeah until you put
it on because that song is eight [__]
minutes of the journey it really is yeah
the high school dance and starts out
it's a slow dance it's like well we're
gonna be here for a minute babe so uh
how much longer you want to stay here
I'm really starting to get a niche okay
did Zeppelin man like like there's no
like
it formula for like like from one tune
to the next it's a totally different
band yeah and that's what inspired me to
write the way I do especially for cmft
because the stuff that I listen to
Growing Up
you would have all of these different
styles on one album and yet it was the
same band and they would just kind of
put it through their own filter you know
I don't know where we lost that or where
it became out of fashion for guys that
play my type of music to just everything
just feels so [__] linear I think
songwriters yeah ghost writers and well
and that very well could be because I've
always written my own [__] yeah so I try
to explore as much as I can and I I've
always kind of had that that road map
man like and maybe it's because they
were
you know the the Pioneers so they could
kind of you know explore different
musical Landscapes and whatnot but I'm
like man [__] that I'm not gonna not do
that I have to I mean I think it's just
gotten industrialized it's like movies
too like it's safer to just like
politically give the people what they
want like make another Avengers
I didn't give a [__] about any of that
stuff I'd rather play stuff I'd rather
risk for a [__] than sit back
and and give them a pillow you know what
I mean it's like I'd rather just [__]
put it out there and go this is how I
feel this is how I want it to sound what
do you think you don't dig it all right
we'll try this one you know at least
it's you like at least you're just being
like nobody's living my [__] life
yeah can you talk the cmf2 right you had
the song midnight yes Bowie inspired I
listened to it today yeah it was
beautiful oh thank you what was the
process like for writing that that song
is actually an old song like um a lot of
the reasons why I started my solo career
is because I had all of these [__]
songs that I've written over the years
I've never had a spot to kind of put
them out you know
and midnight it was a song that I had
actually forgotten that I wrote and I
would found an old demo of it in a
folder on my computer and I went oh [__]
dude I remember this I recorded the demo
for this
back in 2000 when I was actually putting
together the demos for what would be the
Resurgence of Stone Sour wow because and
the project was called Project X
um because that's what we were going to
call it and we didn't realize the name
was taken so that thing went through
like two or three different name changes
at one point it was called superego at
another point was called closure and
then we finally like three or four
[__] names were taken I just called
everybody and I was like listen
let's just call this Stone Sour we
nobody's taken that name nobody wants
the name it's [__] shitty name it's
not a great name it's a [__] it's an
alcoholic drink that's what it's it's a
it's a whiskey Stone Sour that's where
we got the name from we just thought it
was cool we were 20. you know like good
yeah and I was like listen it's it's
everybody from Stone Sour with Josh Rand
you know let's just call it that just we
have a name and we can just put it out
right
and in the thick of things it was
actually the same demo session in 2000
where I'd recorded bother for the first
time when I did a demo for that and I
did a demo for midnight and it was
called something else at the time I
can't remember what the [__] it was
called but it was I I remember listening
to it
what last year and I was like I'm going
to re-record this and I'm going to bring
it in and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
give it that life that it never had you
know and to to and the crazy thing is is
that I can actually relate to that song
more today than I did when I wrote it
because that song is very much about
that Melancholy Vibe you get when you're
feeling
physical depression
and you just need to get yourself
out you just need to get yourself up and
and
move through air feel something in life
get in your [__] car and drive you're
not going anywhere you just need a
reason to be in your car and listen to
the radio other than just sitting in
your driveway like a psychopath you know
it's like I'm just gonna drive I'm gonna
put on some [__] I'm gonna stare into
the dark and I'm gonna allow myself to
feel this [__] but I'm not gonna I I
don't want to feel like I'm just putting
my back against the world so I can feel
it rotate I need to move I need to do
something and that's what that song is
about it's about kind of talking it out
it's a conversation in your own head
where you're just like
okay
I know that I'm gonna have to deal with
this for a few days I know that at some
point it's going to lift that physical
depression and I'm gonna be okay but in
this moment I need to I need to ease
back I need to hold like hold down the
anxiety because I get very anxious when
I know that it's coming
and just prepare myself with the fact
that for three days I'm going to feel
physically numb and I'm not going to be
able to relate to anybody
um and it's actually easier today
because my wife actually understands
like it's the first time that any of my
spouses have really understood this what
I go through and it's because I've
described it to her and I tell her I was
like listen when this comes on it's not
you it has nothing to do with you I
don't control this this is just
something that for whatever reason just
happens to me and I will not feel like
myself I will feel like someone holding
up a you know it's that commercial you
know that they're holding up the
cardboard face and they're just kind of
hiding behind it that's literally what
it feels like it's like do you have to
understand it's not you I just need you
to be patient and I need you to be
supportive and we'll be okay and she's
like done and ever since then I've never
feared
having that happen to me again because I
know my wife has my [__] back and
I've never felt that in my life dude
it's incredible
what do you do if that happens to you
when you're about to go on stage or like
when I'm on well I'm on the road because
I've been so good at at leaning into it
and and going to the Motions it's it's
it's it's it's easier to feel something
when you're in that moment because it's
such a shock to the system whenever
you're in front of an audience
there's so much energy that's going to
happen so regardless of where you're
when you're feeling yeah basically
you're sucking up Theirs to kind of get
through your own you know what I mean
um luckily it's never been debilitating
in that point but I will say this when I
get off stage it's almost like I'm extra
empty because I can give so much oh dude
it's crazy yeah I've I've literally had
moments in hotel rooms where I just I I
just I say to myself it's like I'm not I
can't even lay on the bed I have to lay
on the floor and I have to make myself
do this because my body is just making
me
need it you know so I lay down and I
just stare up there and I lay there
until I'm ready to get up and because I
allow myself to make that decision it
helps me lean into it and and embrace it
and and not look at it as something
negative just something that's in my
life you know it's [__] I don't know
if that's the right way to do it but
that's what's worked for me so far wow
wow sounds like there's like a lot of
growth that you've gone through
this uh like and I'm sure you're sick of
talking about it but I had this MGK
[__] happen like 10 years or 15
years before because you handled it so
well so like maturely almost like big
brother damn with it oh dude I would
have I would have been such an [__]
20 like 50 even 15 years ago I because
because even back then as much as I was
trying to get a hold on my ego back then
I was still leaning into it you know
like it was still just kind of a dog off
of a chain really you know and what I
had to realize is that there are certain
things about him that I'd identify with
man right you know we're both big
personalities we both have massive
mouths you know like we just we both
love the sound of our own [__] voice
let's put it that way you know
um but I can admit that you know I'm not
going to be the [__] who goes you
know I'm oh I'm I'm too you know I'm too
together for that [__] right [__] that
man right right I'm an [__] I can be
you know
um and the fact that
I was able to go you know what I had
just as much
to blame about that situation as he did
you know and I think people didn't
realize that people just wanted to pick
a side instead of look at what was going
on you know and it wasn't until we both
kind of sat because he did it in that
interview and then I did it later
talking to ali
um from from uh Spotify
we were able to both go you know what
I you know I was a dick and I I ran off
at the [__] mouth and it turned into
some [__] you know and that's one of the
reasons why we don't talk about it I got
it got brought up yesterday and I I said
the same thing I was like you know what
I think we both handled it
we both let it explode but then we both
were like you know what this has gone
too far and I even cut off
fans who come up to me and and scream
all they do I mean they screaming
and I'm like okay that was two years ago
right which is crazy when you think
about it so much it's fine man like it's
it's done and buried and we're not going
there you know like I I wish him some
peace and I hope he wishes me some peace
yeah you know because I and and that's
where it needs to stay it's the [__]
where you start you're just gnawing at
it and worrying at it like a bone that
it can make you [__] break your teeth
on something like that yeah and it's
just like at this point man
I just want to make great music I mean
at this point in my life there are only
really three things I want to do is hang
out with my wife be with my kids and
make great music that's all I really
give a [__] about anything else is
frosting or too much flour in the mix
you know
I will Echo what Paul said that you
handled that really pretty I appreciate
it you know and but I will say this man
he was the bigger person after that in
that interview where he said he probably
handled it wrong because he was the
first to say that I I I don't know to be
honest like I I know there was some back
and forth for a minute
and I remembered saying to myself is
like this needs to I I I think I was the
first one to go we're done talking about
this yeah we're not going to talk about
this anymore because I think we both
realize where we're at you know what I'm
saying and then then I think because
maybe because of that he went in in that
interview and said what he did right and
that made me go you know what he's
absolutely right sure and that's where I
came in and was just like you know we're
both
big personalities we both have very
healthy Egos and we both want to [__]
Rule The Rock World sure I mean why not
you know I mean that's the one thing I
was built to do you know so it's you
know once you can
appreciate the fact that the other Seas
where you know where it happened and and
why you can let that [__] go man yeah
well and hearing you talk about it today
I never realized probably throughout it
you're sort of seeing it's like you're
arguing with a younger you a little bit
you know because well and not only that
but I mean he was I mean he's friends
with Sid and according to say he's a
massive Slipknot fan so it's obvious
that he's he knows the stuff that I've
said and done so he knows that I come
from a very raw Place dude you know and
honestly in a lot of ways man Ohio is no
different than than Iowa in a lot of
ways you know so our backgrounds very
very similar so why can't I why am I
going to fall to him for [__] blowing
up because I would have done the same
thing right you know yeah and it comes
back to the point that
just having the ball sack to step up and
admit yeah you didn't handle something
exactly and that's you know and and
maybe that's like the biggest lesson
that I've learned in the last handful of
years is that I'm not always right you
know I'm not always going to handle
something correctly yeah you know yeah
it's never going to end well and if I
don't prove that you can you can retrace
your steps and be
and and and provide some Mia culpa if I
don't put that out there why would I
expect anybody else to do that yeah
exactly you know what I'm saying like if
if I'm gonna [__] about the fact that
nobody's [__] setting an example for
people
what do I expect if I don't [__] try
to do it myself you know it's
it's that whole manifesting thing and I
hate talking about it because a lot of
that [__] makes me cringe like crazy but
it's true if you don't [__] think
about something and then do it why would
you expect it to [__] get done yeah
for sure yeah you're uh you have a heart
out so I know you have a flight to catch
oh yeah there's some people lingering
and they look more and more nervous
jet Suite to Vegas
I'm on Southwest baby
I'm catling with everybody
it's been a real real treat to just do
this deep dive into all this oh dude
yeah we'll [__] do this again I
promise you that and we uh we've got
your solo album right this camera like
let's leave that in at the very top when
I ask oh hell yeah oh yeah what are we
promoting here so everybody knows that
right out of the gate cms2 comes out
September 15th
um uh I go on tour August 25th to
October 7th
um October uh let's see August 25th is
Denver uh you can find tickets on sale
at uh thecourtaylor.com like all that
good [__] cool yeah man it's gonna be
it's gonna be [__] rad yeah we're
playing we're actually playing the wheel
turn here in in uh in October so yeah
yeah if you guys are [__] around man
please come down
yeah yeah for sure man all right they're
banging on them
oh yeah brother thank you man yeah man
that was awesome thanks man I appreciate
it whoa this this thing isn't loaded
right okay let me out let me give you my
number yeah man absolutely here do you
have a bathroom yeah right there I use
it
thanks how about that we had a way more
uh
like authentic and and personal and and
revealing intimate conversation with
Corey Taylor in person than we did on
zoom and now we're Bros telling you I
love this guy I love this guy and I love
mgk2 so I'm glad that they
you know worked out their thing
and what else can I say I love you I
love you I love tight box packing life's
really good these days man life is
really good and I I saw the line cut
um you know just a rough
edit of my special taped in London it
looks unbelievable why is it giving her
this I watched it
sick it's unbelievable so hey I love you
guys thank you
um watch for me on at the fights on uh
this Saturday and Chicago head over here
bobblehead stared at stevo.com yes all
right man later guys
foreign